la promesse sera donc tenue dès l'an
prochain une partie des français ne
paiera plus la taxe d'habitation à terme
en 2020 ce sont 80 % des contribuables
qui seront exonérés une bonne nouvelle à
première vue pour le porte-monnaie même
si les intéressés se méfie des
conséquences d'une telle réforme
il pourra d'achat en plus mais c'est une
dépense en moins pour beaucoup de
beaucoup de français beaucoup de ménages
les communales vont trouver un autre
artifice pour récupérer cet argent de
toute façon ou alors le vent faire des
coupes sombres sur le sur les budgets de
fonctionnement et donc en l'occurrence
façon c'est une mode très mauvaise idée
je suis dépité hâtives comme tout le
monde parce que donc c'est pas amis au
marché que vous à part ce que ça va
donner
c'est une bonne éthique pourquoi parce
que ça permet aux gens de ne pas la
payer puis ça c'est simple ça fait
partie du pouvoir d'achat quoi du côté
des élus locaux les inquiétudes sont là
nombreuses à maurepas le maire les
républicains dénoncent dans un
communiqué une mesure médiatique pour
conforter une cote de popularité dans
cette ville de 19 mille habitants la
taxe d'habitation représentent presque
5e millions d'euros de recettes par an
soit 41 % des rentrées fiscales l'an
passé un manque à gagner qui pourrait
aussi peser lourd dans l'offre de
services à saint quentin en yvelines
si c'était pour diminuer la dette de la
france or c'est pas ça du tout on fait
des ont fait certaines largesses
il va falloir que le compense ailleurs
dont je dire au bout au bout du bout
vous verrez que ce sont les
contribuables qui de toute façon seront
lésés l'exécutif lui se veut rassurant
et confirme que les ressources des
collectivités seront préservés par
l'état elles les deux partis pourront
confronter leurs points de vue sur la
question lors de la conférence des
territoires prévue le 17 juillet
prochain